and the Portuguese first started heading
down the North African coast following
the direction the winds and the ocean
currents already blowing and then they
hit a fundamental problem if we're used
to coasting heading down along the
familiar safety of the coast and using
landmarks to navigate by how'd you get
back home you can't just turn your ship
around and head back up the way you came
to be floating it the very winds and
ocean currents that took you there in
the first place and the realisation
something that must have seemed
completely counterintuitive at the time
is the way to get back home is to turn
away from the safety of the land of the
coast and head deeper out in theack it's
complete what's known as a Volta Domar a
return of the sea heads out deeper into
the ocean until you pick up a different
set of winds and ocean currents and when
he headed further down the African coast
and then completes a wider Volta dream
are to head back they discovered the
Azores
these islands were completely
uninhabited by humans before this point
what the Portuguese were doing in these
very first tentative steps out and the
deep ocean were piecing together these
jigsaw pieces of the global picture the
global pattern of where the winds blow
and the structure the predictable
patterns about where the wind bands are
and the ocean currents they blow around
and we've complete that picture now over
the over the subsequent hundreds of
years since then to map out how the
atmosphere the air high above our heads
churns around the planet to create these
winds that we used to trade by and then
again this makes common sense this is
intuitive to a certain extent around the
equator where it's very sunny the warm
the air the warm air rises dump sort of
rain that's why we find the rainforest
there circulates round through very high
altitude before descending back towards
the surface at around 30 degrees north
and south that dry descending air
creates all of the deserts around the
planet
and then to complete that great vertical
circulation currently atmosphere has to
return to the crater back along the
ground and that's just what we call the
winds and the only or the fact that's
important is that the planet is turning
beneath its own atmosphere as you have
this great circulation currency crates
Coriolis effect to deflect those winds
to one side so either side of the
equator you have these wide bands of
winds that always blow to the west the
trade winds in the next atmospheric
circulation currents it creates winds
that blow in the opposite direction the
westerlies there are these conveyor
belts wrapped around the planet that
give you prevailing winds in opposite
directions if you want to navigate
across an ocean between continents to
trade and then come back again once
you've worked out this trick it's a
simple method of hopping back and forth
between these different conveyor belts
to take you back and forth the way you
want to go and we apply the
understanding that global picture of how
our atmosphere works to build some of
the longest range trade routes of
history which came to determine the
early stage of globalization and the
building of the modern world that we
live in today
the Portuguese completed their dream of
heading south finding the bottom tip of
Africa reaching the Indian Ocean and
then the riches of the Spice Islands
which which they came to monopolize they
found their way of literally
circumnavigating sailing around the
Islamic empire up here to dominate that
spice trade themselves and if you want
to sail around the southern tip of
Africa the only way you can do that but
the way that winds blow is to steer such
a wide loop through the ocean be
basically stumble across Brazil the
reason Brazil speaks Portuguese whereas
the whole rest of South America speaks
Spanish is that's just the way the wind
blows we're trying to get around Africa
the Spanish first with Columbus cross
the Atlantic stumbled in convenience
this content have no right to be there
they cut across
new consonant and became the first eyes
first European eyes to see this whole
new ocean the peaceful ocean the Pacific
and they Spanish then established the
longest range trade routes of the age of
sail which is the Spanish Manila galleon
route and they picked up all their trade
goods from China sailed north to round
the coastline of Japan so they could
pick up the band of westerly winds that
bore them the entire breadth of Pacific
to North America both have been coast
bound to their silver mines in Mexico
because this time China valued silver
even more than it valued gold loaded up
their ships with that precious metal and
then allowed the trade winds to blow
them all the way back again the reason
that California the reason where we are
right now and cities like San Francisco
and Los Angeles and San Diego were
founded in the first place is to
resupply those Spanish galleons because
the only place you can get to on the
North African coast off across the
Pacific is here it's just the way the
winds blow around the planet
the Portuguese discover a shortcut
across the Indian Ocean to then else the
Portuguese and dominates the spice trade
themselves and by exploiting the band of
winds known as the Roaring Forties the
westerly winds in the southern
hemisphere don't encounter any big
continents most the contents from the
northern half of the world there are no
mountain range there are no walls to
block those winds and they get stronger
and stronger and stronger the Roaring
Forties are a literal highway in the
ocean you can shave off weeks of the
crossing time
Australia was discovered by Dutch on
this Dutch captain's on this brower
routes the short cross a short cut
across the Indian Ocean the problem with
using that highway notion is you need to
know when to take your turn off from
that highway from that freeway if you
miss your turn off you plow into
Australia you wouldn't believe the
number of times captains have
accidentally driven and it's straight
into the side of a continent the the
coastline the coral reefs on the west
side of Australia wraps
with shipwrecks where captain's missed
their turn off from the Roaring Forties
from that Highway in the sea the reason
that South Africa became so important
and speaks Afrikaans is that's what you
need to launch your ships from to cross
the Indian Ocean that's why the Dutch
cared about the southern tip of Africa
so much but arguably the most important
trade routes of the subsequent playing
out of history was the North Atlantic
trade triangle this was established
beginning of Industrial Revolution when
Britain North Europe had worked out how
to get machines to make things I think
to rely on craftspeople but very very
cheaply very very quickly manufacturing
things with machinery and those many
fractured products textiles weapons were
sailed down the old Portuguese route to
the North African coast sold there and
then the ship's holes were filled with
slave labor people kidnapped from their
homelands bundled and chains and to hold
these ships taken across that trade
winds banned the colonies of North
Africa but also South North America but
also South America and then forced to
work on the plantations growing raw
plant materials tea coffee sugar cotton
and those raw materials were then taken
along the Weslie banda winds backed to
north europe where they were converted
by using our machinery in for textiles
in the cloths which we could then trade
back down to North Africa and so on and
so on the North Atlantic trade triangle
was an economic cog sat across the ocean
being blown round and round by that
global wind machine and generating huge
profits for its masters for its slave
masters and all of this story of his
building of these vast trade routes are
dictated by where the wind blows these
wind bands specify where you put your
trade routes and therefore where you
need your ports where you put your
fortresses the entire pattern of
European expansion and colonialism and
empire building and the beginnings of
glue
realization made the modern world was
dictated by the atmospheric dynamics and
in these wind bands
[Music]